[Music]
happy Diwali to all my Indian fans so a
lot of you have been requesting for
another healthy India meal plan in my
previous India meal plan video I shared
some really simple and useful tips to
cook Indian food without sacrificing the
flavours yet keeping it healthy so do
check it out on my youtube channel
Indian cooking can be complicated and
also time-consuming so I'm recreating
some of my favourite recipes which are
really simple fast and also healthy this
recipes are vegan friendly they are
gluten free and also dairy free so we've
got breakfast lunch and also dinner for
breakfast I'm making my version of a
savory Indian pancakes the ingredients
you need are 1 cup of rice flour 1/3 cup
of red onion diced 1/3 cup of carrot
grater
1 red chili finely chopped about 3
tablespoons of coriander finely chopped
1/2 a tbsp of vegetable oil
approximately 1/3 cup of warm water in a
bowl mix in the rice flour onions
carrots coriander chilies combined well
then add in the water little by little
to make the dough if it's too thick then
add in more water grease a nonstick pan
with oil over medium low heat
pull the batter equally onto the pan to
cook the pancakes this should make about
6 pancakes guys don't worry if your
pancakes do not look perfect cook for
about 3 to 4 minutes on one side until
it is slightly brown then flip over and
continue to cook until the pancakes are
done serve warm instead of the sugar
loaded sweet pancakes these pancakes are
filled with vegetables so each pancake
has about 120 calories so have three to
four pancakes for breakfast to fill your
body and
the energy you need for the day for
lunch I'm making rice noodle upma this
recipe is great because you can prep
ahead and bring it out to work or school
what you'll need are three ounces of
rice noodles one small onion diced one
red chili finely chopped one sprig of
curry leaves 1 tablespoon of vegetable
oil 1 tablespoon of chana dal half a
teaspoon of cumin quarter teaspoon of
black mustard seeds cut a cup of cashew
nuts haft 3/4 cup of mixed carrots corn
and peas
let's start by prepping the noodles
stock noodles in boiling water for about
5 minutes or until soft then drain and
set aside in a non-stick pan heat oil
over medium high heat add in the cumin
black mustard seeds and Dow fry very
quickly for about 3 to 4 minutes until
the Daltons slightly golden and fragrant
then stir in curry leaves chili mixed
vegetables The Onion's cashew nuts saute
very quickly for another two to three
minutes and two cashews are slightly
roasted finally mix in the noodles and
stir until all the ingredients are
evenly distributed at this point you can
go ahead and taste your dish add more
salt if needed garnish with a little bit
of coriander and serve warm so this is
my take on rice noodle upma which is
more like a stir-fried noodle dish it is
easy quick and very convenient to be
eaten each serving has about 370
calories if you want to you can even mix
a protein into the dish such as meat
fish tempeh or even tofu this is your
dish to experiment with as for dinner
I'll be serving chickpeas sweet potato
greens in coconut milk why you'll need
are 1 medium onion diced 1 garlic clove
peeled 1 ginger piece thumb-sized peeled
and sliced
one red chilli finely sliced half a
tablespoon of vegetable oil
half a teaspoon of turmeric powder 1
teaspoon of cumin powder 1 teaspoon of
garam masala 2 cups of pumpkin peeled
and diced one can of chickpeas rinsed
and drained about 150 grams of sweet
potato greens one cup of coconut milk 1
cup of vegetable stock let's start by
prepping the paste in a food processor
add in the onion ginger garlic and
chilli blend very quickly until it
becomes a paste in a large nonstick pan
heat oil over medium high heat fry the
paste very quickly for one to two
minutes until fragrant and then add in
the spices turmeric cumin and garam
masala continue to fry very quickly for
another minute next add chickpeas and
pumpkin stir and mix well then add in
vegetable stock the coconut milk and
bring to a simmer and allow all the
ingredients to cook for about 20 to 30
minutes until the pumpkin softens and
the sauce thickens don't forget to stir
occasionally
so once the pumpkin has softened then
add in the sweet potato greens and cook
until wilted serve warm I just love the
nutty and earthy flavor of chickpeas
combined with the sweetness of pumpkin
and also the creaminess of coconut milk
this dish is just bursting with flavors
and it is so delicious so one serving
has about 267 calories you can serve
this with a cup of rice or 2 chapatis I
hope you loved all these recipes I like
to keep it simple balanced and moderate
do try this recipes out take pictures
and share them with me at Joanna's
official hashtag the choice of recipes
let me know which is your favorite in
the comments below do also like this
video share this video with your friends
and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more healthy recipes and workout
videos don't forget to turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new video
happy Diwali